hey crazies
the transporter problem it's been a
topic of philosophical debate for as
long as the tech has existed in sci-fi I
recently had the opportunity to ask
other YouTubers whether or not they'd
use one I would probably use it only
when I was like 90. I would say no I
would not be the first to use it
I think I'd use it
no no
So my answer is probably not so my
answer is no oh absolutely of course
they had a lot more to say about it than
just yes or no this device raises
questions about what it means to exist
what makes you you
foreign
[Music]
essentially what we're talking about
here is teleportation but that can work
differently depending on the fiction
Nightcrawler from Marvel shunts himself
into an alternate realm in the video
game portal an actual hole is open that
connects two points in space other
stories use dimensional folds or
wormholes all of those options would be
philosophically more appealing
unfortunately Star Trek's Destroyer I
mean transporter is the most realistic
according to the Star Trek technical
manual I got for my 10th birthday you
step into this device's chamber it scans
your entire body clothes and items it
then takes you apart at the particle
level briefly stores you in a buffer to
run calculations and uses that scan to
put you back together somewhere else
can we do that no well then how is that
at all realistic I didn't say it was
realistic I said it was the most
realistic of the fictions for example
wormholes require unobserved things like
exotic matter that's matter with
properties that don't make sense like
negative mass or something
the Star Trek transporter only uses
physics we've already confirmed by
observation quantum mechanics
as far as Quantum is concerned
teleportation should be possible we may
not have done it with objects or people
yet but we have done it with individual
particles so yeah we certainly don't
have teleportation yet
you're terrified and maybe I'm
you know hundreds of thousands of people
had tried it out beforehand and
everything was fine but my fear is that
you'd have like like there would be an
error with a copy like it might be
subtle like you lose a tiny little bit
every time I don't know like I feel like
if we were thinking about what that
would look like in our world if that was
brought in there'd be so much like
like short-term versus long-term effects
that no one would know about until
people had used it for a really long
time but do you want to be the guinea
pig for the long-term effects even if
there's no short-term effects that are
like immediately apparent
once we do finally figure it out there
might be some potential problems in Star
Trek alone there have been several plots
centered around transporter accidents so
I think we can all understand a little
hesitation
early on it'll probably only be approved
for cargo not people or animals we'll
need to work out a few Kinks first
well I feel like all of these these
Kinks will be worked out by this point
right if it's a time-tested thing we
would have studies on like who is the
original or have some at least some idea
so I would feel if it's time tested it's
been used a lot I use it for sure it's
it's a convenience at that point
assuming we work out all those Kinks it
should be possible to safely teleport a
person not easy but possible
flying isn't easy it's never been easy
but statistically it's safe I imagine
teleportation would get there too
eventually get in the beam losers we're
going shopping okay what about the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle doesn't
prevent teleportation what allow me to
explain
in Star Trek they explain this problem
away with something called a Heisenberg
compensator but you don't actually need
to explain it away like that
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle is
all about direct measurements of
particle properties
for example the more definite you
measure position the less definite
momentum becomes the reverse is also
true the more definite the momentum the
less definite the position that pattern
pops up all over quantum mechanics with
many pairs of properties but teleporters
won't necessarily be taking direct
measurements if a particle is in a
superposition of classical States like
this that's perfectly fine it can stay
that way in fact we would prefer it to
stay that way the superposition is
probably there for a reason and
collapsing it could be bad it could
cause some of those accidents we've
already said we've hypothetically worked
out we don't need the superposition to
collapse we just need to know what the
superposition is so we can reproduce it
somewhere else do you know how many
nights I have not been able to sleep
because I'm thinking about the
transporter problem is this a sympathies
problem right because like if you if you
get if all your atoms and molecules are
taken apart and put together somewhere
else it's a different you any
conversation about teleportation
inevitably arrives at the ship of
Theseus
you might have heard of this before but
I'm gonna run through it real quick
anyway
in Greek mythology there was this guy
named Theseus over time his wooden ship
would Decay and pieces of it would be
replaced eventually every plank of wood
and every ore was replaced is it still
theseus's ship what if we took all the
rotten pieces and assembled a ship out
of them is that theseus's ship or is the
new one a ship what makes a thing a
thing if your particles are disassembled
and then new particles are used to like
reassemble you somewhere else is that
still you well that depends on what you
consider to be you if you use a
transporter are you still the same
person that's kind of what we're getting
at here right and I think that you know
the resulting person who was transported
believes that they're the same person
and we have to accept that I remember
talking to my buddy in college about
this and he considered it's someone who
has all your memories and experiences
and thinks they're you but they're still
not you and I can see that perspective a
lot the new guy would not be me he'd be
like a clone thankfully quantum
mechanics forbids cloning the only
allowed operations are ones where the
original is destroyed quantum
teleportation is possible Quantum
cloning is not
at least not perfect Quantum cloning
they've been able to clone qubits with
83 Fidelity but that's a far cry from
100 and that's a single qubit in a
quantum computer not a whole person
the point is if we did manage to
successfully make Quantum clones of
people these clones would be at least a
little different from the original
they'd be their own unique entities
but this still doesn't address the
continuity issue what are you what am I
feel like I use one
every day it's called sleep like I go to
sleep
and then I wake up and I'm in a slightly
different place in my bed and I don't
remember how I got there was my selfhood
interrupted did you disappear like when
you sleep when you when you wake up are
you the same person as went to bed you
certainly have the feeling of continuity
but is it actual continuity and then
maybe there's a question of does it
matter I can assure you sleep is still
existence I've experienced non-existence
and it's terrifying
of course I was still alive while
unconscious and I think this is the core
of the transporter problem
many of us like to think we exist
independent of our bodies that we have a
soul or something like it if we can be
alive but not conscious then it should
be possible to be conscious but not
alive
right
if we're disassembled at the particle
level and put back together does that
Soul go with us or is it left behind in
a new soul is made in the new body I
honestly don't know a soul is
immeasurable if it's immeasurable then
it's not scientific the only way to
proceed scientifically is to assume that
anything immeasurable isn't important to
be clear I'm not saying that Souls don't
exist again I don't know that I'm just
saying they're not important for the
universe to function given that
assumption what can we say about
existence I'm certainly a collection of
atoms that thinks I'm me and I think
anyone I've ever met would say the same
thing about themselves like you know the
question is like does your Consciousness
like translate to the new body like what
is your Consciousness like I'm a very
material materialistic viewer honestly I
think Consciousness is just an emergent
property of everything going on in
amongst your neurons and the person on
the other end has no idea because all
their memories and stuff has been like
reshaped exactly the way you so to that
person it's just like this continuity of
Consciousness nobody actually knows
where Consciousness comes from
some hypotheses say it emerges from the
complex electrical patterns in the brain
others say quantum mechanics is what
makes Consciousness possible but either
way it comes down to the behavior of our
microscopic parts
if a machine existed that could
disassemble those parts and then put
them back together in exactly the same
fashion then scientifically speaking
that new person is you in every way that
matters to the universe
plus the cells in our bodies replace
their own atoms all the time it's not
like we're the same collection of atoms
we were even a year ago if I were to
shine a laser on the wall you'd see a
dot but if I move that dot around the
wall it's the same dot right but we
certainly talk about it like it's the
same dot but the dot in every single
frame of this video is made of different
photons yet we still consider it to be
the same dot the Star Trek transporter
does the same thing it just does it
suddenly which breaks the illusion of
continuity and there would be a new
Michael somewhere else who felt
continuous with me but that I would be
gone
doesn't that continuity matter though I
thought it did but apparently not to
everyone
oh absolutely yeah to be able to travel
anywhere in the world okay
Universe Universe yeah if enough people
use this and there were no
issues I'd use it I think I
think I'd use it
okay if it was long term that looked
that long term
I would probably use it but I feel
queasy about that in my soul
so what I personally use a Star Trek
transporter
I mean I usually say no but I think if I
was in a situation where it was
life-threatening not to use it I'd
probably do it yeah I'm gonna go find a
dark corner now and yeah work my way
through this huge thank you to everyone
who let me interview them you can find
links to their channels down in the
doobly-doo if you haven't already you
should go check them out
anyway crazies would you use a Star Trek
transporter let us know in the comments
Thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special Thanks goes out to my generous
patreon patrons and YouTube members like
James younger DDS our new Asylum
counselor thanks Dr Younger don't forget
to subscribe if you'd like to keep up
with us and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
a featured comment comes from jerseymash
who gave some detail about injection
molding apparently my chips and cracks
are remnants of the manufacturing
process not actually damage I guess
that's what I get for having almost zero
engineering experience anyway thanks for
watching